hi there I'm Anna Prosser Robinson for
gamespot and I am on the e3 2014 show
floor about two minutes until the doors
open right now I'm able to walk around
pretty comfortably I'm not getting you
know trampled or stampeded by a large
tide of very enthusiastic gamers but
that is about to change so I just wanted
to give you a quick look of the floor
plan here at e3 we've got microsoft
behind me they introduce some really
exciting things some exclusive titles
like fable legends and sunset overdrive
as well as a halo collection so we're
looking at some really cool new games
from them also they announced a Kinect
less Xbox one for those of you who
aren't into being watched so that's
pretty exciting sony also really feeling
comfortable this year after a great
reaction last year to their press
conference focused on the game still on
the feedback from the community and
showed a lot of indie games which is
something that i was really excited to
see rounding out kind of the big three
if you will over there behind you do is
nintendo nintendo showing off a whole
bunch of really exciting classic
characters in new titles for example
we've got super smash brothers which is
taking up a large portion of the booth
as well as a new Legend of Zelda game
we've got a Mario maker which will allow
you to make some of your own Mario
levels which is something that I'm sure
lots of us have wanted to do since we
were kids and in the center of it all of
course is the game spot booth we're
going to be bringing you coverage of the
conference all three days showing you
exciting new games talking to developers
to live streams myself and lisa foiles
we'll be checking in on those and right
now i believe the tide will be starting
soon usually they kind of announce it
over the loudspeaker when they're going
to let everyone in and all the
exhibitors kind of brace themselves and
get ready right now the energy is just
really electric we've got lights and
sounds and everything coming off these
booths and everyone is kind of standing
around watching the doors waiting for
that tied to flow last year I almost got
trampled so watch out
I'm getting my my protective stance
ready and I see some of my friends that
I I saw at the front of the line running
in showing their badges I'm getting
ready to go see the things that they
were looking forward to most as we go
through the rest of the day if you want
me to visit anything or check out
anything in particular be sure to tweet
at me at Anna brosser with hashtag
gamespot III and I think I better go
look for somewhere safe at this point